we're drafting the most iconic jersey
numbers in the nfl
question for you to determine the first
pick which player
changed his number from 96 to 99
in honor of jerome brown in 1992 and
then went on to win defensive player of
the year
that season right i saw this i mean wow
you is it that easy you're thinking it's
that easy i i
i i mean 96 there's only one guy i can
think of
92. he was 92 and he went nineteen
defensive player of the year
no he was not 96 right went to 99 in
honor of jerome brown
and won defensive player of the year in
92. i'm gonna say it's clyde simmons
because that's the only 96 i can think
of
who is it cortez kennedy
oh my gosh yep i am i wouldn't yeah
good one there man cortez kennedy yeah a
baller who kind of
yeah doesn't get the credit he ever
deserves because he's never on a big
winning team there in seattle wow
yeah all right you know and and these
are largely driven by personal
preferences and memories and
and i've told this story before for me
the moment
that i realized the nfl was a big deal
was the immaculate reception game and
frank o'haras was
you know the rookie that everyone loved
in and around pittsburgh back in the
early 70s and
that the house i grew up in was number
32. there was always been that resonance
for 32. right
without question without question the
first number i think of
when football comes around is 32. i got
it and it's been it's because of franco
harris
yeah i i hear that i mean 30 i mean 32
of course is an iconic number two
because when i think of 32 i think of
jim brown
always right off the bat but damn
there's a lot of
studs that have worn 32 over the year
marcus allen
and so on um okay good one by you i
think when i just think of numbers i
i i don't know why um
i just think like when i think 56 i
think lawrence taylor all right
that that to me uh is is one that will
always just be ingrained in my brain i
mean lawrence taylor
trendsetter nothing like him in the
history of the sport
until he got there he was almost 20 30
years ahead of his time as far as that's
concerned
yeah i'm biased and i got to see it
every sunday growing up and all of that
but
man you know when i think of football
and defensive football
i think of lawrence taylor and that
attitude and everything he brought to it
and 56 to me is iconic because of him
next one for me and again this is what's
wired into your brain from when you're a
kid it's 12.
and 12 was just the default quarterback
number the original tb12 terry bradshaw
now tom brady has completely co-opted it
to the point where
you think of 12 you think of brady but i
think at 12 i think a bradshaw and
that just was like yeah quarterback's
number 12. quarterback's number 12. even
though plenty of great quarterbacks four
different numbers to me
first number that a quarterback could
wear is 12. yeah 12 i mean stallback
bradshaw stabler rogers
brady i mean it's unreal how many greats
have been 12 right i mean
it really is that way uh it's probably
the most special number actually all in
all of football
when you really break it down uh you
know when i i'm i guess i'm taking more
of the route of just
one like a guy that i think of that's
like when you just think that number you
think of that person and the other one
19. you know we haven't seen any 19s and
that's johnny you
that's johnny u-time to me that's just
like when i see that number
it doesn't matter what sport it is i
could be watching a basketball game and
seeing 19 i go
johnny you i just it comes into my brain
oh there's a baseball guy 19. johnny you
that's it it's just it's not a very you
know popular number
it ever has been uh and of course it
belongs to him as far as football is
concerned
yeah and it is weird that it never
really caught on there weren't a lot of
guys in the 70s and 80s who
emulated johnny unitas that wanted to
wear number 19. just
and it's it's not like something that
every team's got a 19
19 is probably available on more rosters
right now than not
but uh i don't know maybe just people
thought we could never live up to johnny
united so i'm not even gonna try
uh the other one for me he's got to be
88 88's always
did alan page back to the 70s and
growing up but
there's something about 88 and i didn't
like it when they started letting
receivers wear numbers in the teens i
think they should only wear numbers in
the 80s
because it's those and and the numbers
in the 80s and specifically 88 that that
that to me was the receiver lynn swann
even though it was alan page on the
defensive side it was lynn swann on the
offensive side yeah right there's
i mean yeah michael irvin you know those
guys that guy that uh
drew pearson and that great catch he had
i mean there's been some good
that would be a reason to not like
that's a good one
um 12 and 80. i can't believe 12 and 88
are on my list
i i know but i kind of tried to be a
little i'm going to go i'm going to go
92
just with like when i think of iconic
numbers 92 i think of reggie white like
i
i really when i sit here and think about
i go what other great 92s are there in
the history of football
i mean michael strahan good job pete
that's one certainly
but that just again 92 is ingrained in
my brain
and i think about reggie white every
time because i watched him smoosh my
father for eight years in a row
so i'm just always like oh 92 it like
makes me shake in my boots
other ones for me 7-1 and double zero we
talked about double zero last week jim
otto hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports